allô allô Bernard
bonsoir c'est Olivier Valérie de Noël
surprise
c'est Olivier et Valérie de Noël
allô Bernard
Bernard
5 4 3 2
dans le cas du champagne c'est mauvais
dans le cas du champagne on sait que
c'est ça commence
mais non tu penses que je fais aller
les déclarants de récolte les 15000
déclarants de récolte
la récolte de la cuvée 86 c'est pas bon
excuse-moi ça devrait être bon je crois
que j'en ai mis un sacré paquet dans mon
verre
j'ai soif je prendrais bien un coup de
rouge moi
j'aimerais bien un coup de rouge et des
marrons glacés Maïté quel est le menu du
jour
[Rires]
je reste un peu de temps peut-être pour
faire une autre recette oui un autre
homard un autre une araignée
et ensuite Maïté est-ce que vous avez
encore une autre recette de moules bien
sûr on va faire la mouklade
non un plat pour des amoureux sur la
plage
une décision qui pardon excusez-moi
je suis perdu une décision qui suicide
très sérieuse dans les milieux
politiques par des aides directes aux
revenus
il faudra que les autres institutions
prennent d'autres décisions qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que 200
000 francs en moins
recommencer ça va pas ça poser une
question directe
vous venez bientôt le premier février il
va y avoir une nouvelle
on fait chier ce truc car un certain
nombre d'entre eux demandaient des
commentaires comportaient
ça a beaucoup bafouillé ou pas quand au
professeur Jean loi adjoint au maire de
Paris il a fait savoir hier qui est du
souhaitait être un culte de Michel
garretta le coin sur cette affaire que
l'on confuse avec Alban mit cosy Didier
Séguéla lui il a 16 ans il habite
Pamiers dans l'Ardèche pardon
excusez-moi excusez-moi j'ai dit Ardèche
au lieu d'Ariège Didier Séguéla lui il a
16 ans il habite Pamiers dans l'Ardèche
dans la oh pardon excusez-moi j'ai dit
j'arrête pas de dire à rien Ardèche au
lieu d'Ardèche retour en France dimanche
l'agriculture une grande désertification
au niveau de l'agricole
et puis le budget il y a beaucoup de
il ne suffit pas de voter des
il ne s'agit pas d'être notable pour
défendre les Français dans la misère les
Français ça existe il faut il faut en
prendre conscience que nous avons un
programme établi
vous pouvez pas faire un montage avec
tout ça
pourquoi vous êtes là ce matin et bien
voilà nous revendiquons
le romanican
le revendiquant sur
une
revendiquons
pour les poubelles surtout parce que mon
mari il sait pas porté
qui ont été adjugés autour de 24 et
26000 balles 26000 francs pardon autant
dire que c'était vraiment une affaire et
puis on a pu suivre également le défilé
de John juley Auguste qui présente des
modèles transparents que vous allez
peut-être voir en transparence
en tout cas d'une Julie Auguste et sans
doute un pseudonyme vous n'avez pas vu
mais ce qui importe c'est justement de
ne pas de voir mais ce qui est important
c'est de savoir ce que l'on voit et non
pas ce qui se cache derrière et noyer
les installations électriques et
informatiques ni sans racemite Richard
de Silvestre
de contrôle qui n'a rien à contrôler en
temps normal
alors pour répondre à la demande de
milliers téléspectateurs qui nous ont
réclamés une chanson Véronique Sanson
Annie Cordy en tous les cas je
souhaitais vous remercier parce que je
crois que c'est grâce à vous que cette
Annie Girardot pardonnez-moi Annie non
des milliers d'hommes et de femmes
descendent dans la rue pour réclamer le
départ du président
il vaut mieux s'appeler ma mère c'est
plus facile à dire
c'est en plus déjà vu la télé elle est à
côté de bar à pied
c'est comment prochainement à l'heure
monsieur
vous pensez des hommes politiques
déjà des des hommes politiques
à louer pour 50 ans Diego Garcia aux
États-Unis
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre Messieurs les Députés
masseurs mon directeur
Mesdames et Messieurs les jurés monsieur
Labé Monseigneur monsieur Dupont
monsieur Durand mon Général mes frères
mes amis mes chiens bonsoir bonjour et
bienvenue à tous
les
garanties
on est prêt presque
et vous me mettez déjà qui sont les
trois poils sur le caillou sont
complètement collés Henri est-ce que tu
me rendrais un grand service
c'est d'aller dans ma placard si tu
arrives à l'ouvrir et de m'apporter des
cravates oui parce qu'il paraît que ça
ne va pas
de mieux pas seulement pas tellement
mieux bon vous n'aimez pas ça José
comme ça
ça te va
hein
j'étais très bien mais pas pour paraître
pour parler aux Français à la télévision
j'aime pas ça José voudrait que c'est
mieux aussi Nicolas
ce qui est important
[Musique]
il y a un connard d'applaudissements
pour Marie-Christine et qui a bien
défendu et qui a fait tri
cible alors nous on va sourire parce
qu'il fait beau frais mais bon très
frais vous avez dû sortir votre
instrument comme tout le monde le
grattoir je veux dire pour le gène sur
la voiture et en effet ce matin il a
fait extrêmement froid partout des
températures à fairees à 0 degré et cet
après-midi nous aurons de la chance
puisque nous aurons beaucoup de soleil
avec encore des résidus de brouillard
sur les Landes sur le Massif Central et
sur la vallée de la Saône et un autre
instrument le thermomètre pour vous dire
qu'il fait très froid
non ici allez on va voir les
températures les températures il fait
doux aujourd'hui vous allez le constater
assez vite si vous ouvrez votre femelle
votre fenêtre votre votre fenêtre vous
infirmières qui bourrait qui mourait
beaucoup dans les hôpitaux
et bien voilà cette semaine dans
l'actualité comme Bernard vous l'a dit
le problème de la grève des infirmières
rencontres qui mouraient beaucoup dans
les hôpitaux une Brède de la tuberculose
donc Bernard on va reparler aussi
il lui a fait beaucoup de
c'est une véritable andouille c'est à
dire qu'elle est pas hachée elle est
faite de la nièce de l'intérieur du port
qui sont tournés à la ficelle avec
passage de la robe sur deux doigts elles
sont faites à la main sur deux doigts
seul travail tout à fait extraordinaire
j'ai dû faire à mon père que j'ai fait
d'ailleurs moi aussi mais pas avec
beaucoup de talent la queue toujours la
queue des kilomètres de queue alors
évidemment cela promet de belles queues
de belles queues
étaient sécrété par le rire ou le
bien-être voilà
bon on va voir en tout cas avec
gélatine
ça reste un peu
par exemple bon alors le rire est donc
important pour la santé on l'a vu que
tout à l'heure et on vous en fait la
démonstration tout au long de cette
émission on va maintenant se tourner
vers le Japon en effet alors attention
que de filles donc de toute façon il y a
de l'avenir pour pour choisir en
fonction de leur sexe ou est-ce que ça
veut dire
[Rires]
le plus dur c'est de tirer ses
partenaires et de tirer surtout sa sa
jeune campagne mais qui a été super
parce que elle est elle était jusqu'au
bout avec beaucoup de difficultés mais
elle était jusqu'au bout alors à Poissy
combien de fois avez-vous tiré combien
de fois ça fait déjà plusieurs années
que je tire et je tire toutes les
semaines alors je peux pas vous dire
combien toute chaque semaine je continue
de tirer nous avons engagé de gros
crédits nous avons des grosses affaires
sur le dos il faut la faire prostituer
prosterner pardon est-ce que vous aimez
les femmes un peu enrobées
bien sûr je préfère les femmes enrobées
il y a plus à manger au lit il y a plus
de chaleur qui dégagent et puis vont
sans plus en sécurité à votre avis
pourquoi les gens divorcent plus
surtout en France c'est que les femmes
elles baissent trop et puis que les mecs
ils baissent pas assez il y a des gens
qui sont pas normal je pense qu'il y a
des gens qui sont pas normal fini le
cochon Jean-Daniel mais bienvenue c'est
un rapport sans transition comme dirait
Dequin fini le cochon et bienvenue le
rap dans le calendrier chinois l'année
du cochon arrive à son terme et laisse
place donc à celle du rat en Chine c'est
l'occasion j'en étais sûr une grande
fête de trois jours à Pékin on va
rejoindre nos correspondants Jérôme
bonniettriste dans Le Braz qui vous
souhaite une bonne année l'exemple le
plus inadmissible fait cette sangle qui
va tenir enchaîner une truie durant
toute sa vie
pas par derrière les filles docteur quel
est le problème avec les bénitiers
géants
les problèmes sont des problèmes de
ça
la célèbre mangue appréciée par le géant
Ravana
mais ce traitement qu'il a subi est un
mal nécessaire dans la mesure où vous
allez constater avec nous que j'en ai
ras-le-bol je suis crevé je sais plus
quoi vous dire c'est un capybara un
capybara c'est le plus gros rongeur du
monde qui vit en Amérique du Sud qui
doit peser à peu près 50 kg c'est très
lourd c'est très dense
qui vit actuellement c'est pas un animal
préhistorique
en tout cas sa vie en troupeau de d'une
vingtaine d'individus et il s'en va
en liberté et vivre en liberté ils
adorent l'eau ces animaux qui plongent
maintenant
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
pipi
et alors allez-y continue je vous en
prie pas peur
faites votre commentaire
c'est un animal qui vit en Amérique du
Sud
un petit chien qui était laissé en
liberté dans la dans la maison et le
la dame a laissé le four grand ouvert et
le chinchilla dans sa tête c'était un
terrier et un refuge il a sauté dans le
four qui est allumé et bon il était
vraiment brûlé gravement on n'a pas pu
le tirer d'affaires
non c'est vrai qu'il y a vraiment c'est
pire que les enfants puissent qu'on ne
peut pas contrôler les choses autre
chose qui va pourtant pas vous faire
rire c'est le garage faites attention
dans le garage le chat ou le chien
arrive toujours quand le maître est là
et on risque de l'écraser c'est aussi un
accident banal les cheminées aussi les
animaux se précipitent dans le feu très
volontiers ou se font enfermer dans les
cheminées
donc vous faire très très attention les
insecticides comme a dit tout à l'heure
Philippe aussi
le pauvre chat qui était à l'intérieur
je m'en remets pas
c'est vraiment très difficile
[Rires]
et là c'est très grave
attention arrête de montrer ton trou de
balle
[Rires]
on est du mauvais côté alors vous avez
voilà c'est pas heureusement
généralement
un chien
donc vous avez reçu une lettre Jules et
Agnès une dame vous avez écrit pour vous
dire mon chien se traîne par terre se
traîne les fesses par terre il fait le
traîneau les trois quarts du temps c'est
un problème de glandes
je vais essayer de faire le plus
les deux les deux les deux glandes
anales d'un chien
la queue est envers le haut et donc ces
deux glandes anales en principe le chien
c'est le grand sécrète un produit une
substance qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est
que ces glandes de temps en temps de se
vide pas et à ce moment-là ça provoque
une inflammation une inflammation je
crains je crains pour le restant de
la suite bien alors en sortie de ce
sujet sur les animaux les personnes
âgées bon merde [ __ ] j'arrête j'ai
marché dans la merde attends on refait
tout attends je peux pas continuer comme
ça c'est dégueulasse le tromper le
quitter acheter des choses très chères
acheter une voiture
parce que je lui dis je me fais déjà
chier avec un bonhomme je me ferais pas
chier avec deux
alors le tromper
on va poser la question puis vous allez
dire autre chose que chier parce qu'on
est à table quand les gens vont au
ettes pas de la lecture
et puis Toulouse dans les toilettes ou
alors ceux qui n'ont rien pris
ons
il y a pas de sujet
quand on est là-bas qu'on a rien à faire
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire et bien on
peut lire on peut s'informer on peut se
cultiver comme il a appelé sa culture
elle m'envoie
mais c'est génial parce que
ça prend moins de place je crois ça fait
pas de bruit bref c'est la chasse d'eau
de l'avenir et c'est vrai que nous
sommes en période de chasse donc ça ne
pouvait pas mieux tomber
bon allez qu'est-ce qu'on fait
maintenant attendez je vais petite fiche
quelque part
la transition va pas être facile
on va pas
consacré
c'est un spécial pompier
comme ça non pas comme ça
et voilà ça vous fait quoi là
[Rires]
suppositoires
au maximum pendant 2 minutes
j'ai mal entendu
salut les guides heureux de vous
bon alors finalement ce qui coûte moins
cher à Biarritz c'est bien ça
que nous vous proposons ce soir nous
arrivons à la fin de ce magazine avec
Michel
d'incinération que trouve-t-on d'abord
les restes de tout incinération ça se
commande un petit peu
j'ai perdu ma boule en attendant on a la
chance ici de traiter nos ordures on les
ramasse et on les brûle et c'est pas par
tout le cas
coupe stop lâche pas je suis l'invité ce
soir de l'équipe du dimanche
[Rires]
est évacué sur une civière sérieusement
touchée et là regardez bien PAF les
secouristes ne remettent dans le vin
heureusement plus de peur que de mal
mais quel chou pour non oui ma chérie
est parti je suis tout seul pour le judo
Jean-Paul Jaude qui s'est venu avec nous
toi
[Applaudissements]
on a vécu un grand moment
bon je vous le refasse c'était utile
d'aller voir la champignonnes olympique
de gigot seulement ça pouvait être des
courses de kangourous disons qu'est-ce
que ça m'arrangerait c'est vrai c'est
toujours les jours
ras-le-bol bon alors cette fois-ci c'est
le tiercé à Longchamp pourvu que je me
plante pas je voudrais avant tout
remercier tous ceux et toutes celles qui
ont passé cette soirée avec nous cette
soirée on croise avec nous et il faut
rappeler que lundi prochain font tous
les idiots autour de nous depuis tout à
l'heure jamais arrivé à garder notre
sérieux jusqu'à la fin faites appel à de
vieilles connaissances enfin de vieilles
connaissances c'est une façon de parler
c'est pas possible aujourd'hui
j'arriverai pas à 11h nous vous
proposons de suivre en direct la messe
de l'Assomption en direct de de gruyère
en Suisse
je suis jamais arrivé
avec vous ce soir
[Musique]
quand même à midi
un programme destiné à nos jeunes amis
avec
et puis la casse de l'oncle Tom
voilà je vous souhaite une très bonne
nuit bonsoir
j'espère au moins que notre gaieté vous
aura mis en joie le prochain rendez-vous
de l'actualité demain à 13h avec
Jean-Pierre Pernaut bonsoir ça c'est une
très bonne soirée
[Musique]